quarante ans sans savoir ce qui est
arrivé à son enfant difficile d'imaginer
une peine plus grande que celle qu'ont
vécu plusieurs familles in ou d'une
communauté de la basse-côte-nord enquête
les accompagner à la recherche
d'explications et à percer le mystère
aqua chipie 1972 une petite communauté
de 80 autochtones habite au bord de la
rivière saint-augustin en basse côte
nord
viennent tout juste d'entrer dans leur
première maison encore hier il vivait
sous la tente et est un nomade sur
l'abonnement des sceaux il était mal
dans leur maison y'a même pas soi même
dans ces boissons lors cette année là
plusieurs enfants tombent malades venus
patent au bâton et tout c'est beaucoup
il faisait de la fièvre
quand on n'était plus sous la tente il y
avait des maisons à ce moment là les
enfants sont évacués par la voie des
airs
car il n'y a pas de route vers l'hôpital
de blanc sablon à 200 kilomètres seul
sans leurs parents
ouattara chaque fois qu'un de mes
enfants a été hospitalisé et pour
l'intérêt on interdisait de la compagnie
n'ont pas ainsi en quelques mois
huit enfants vont passer partir 8 pour
une si petite communauté
autant dire une saignée jeu le savoir
puisqu'il se pensait vraiment pas ce que
sont décédés à coup une maladie
ces enfants on les reverra jamais mon
petit fils
on est souvent les ai vu mon nom j'ai
pas vu est-ce qu'on vous le montrez
votre fils la ville rouge ou marron
pas quoi chipie 2015 quarante ans plus
tard
la communauté a grossi les maisons plus
récentes ont remplacé les premières mais
les parents ne savent toujours pas ce
qui est arrivé à leurs enfants
le traumatisme vécu en silence une
blessure collective
c'est ici donc commence nous recherche
pour percer le mystère
keystone à l'eau avait déjà cinq enfants
lorsqu'elle a quitté la tente pour sa
première maison la même année trois de
ses enfants deviennent malades
chantal micheline et patrick se sont
envolés vers l'hôpital de blanc-sablon
jardiner son mari ne les ont jamais revu
je pensais qu'ils avaient été assassinés
à blanc-sablon comme des moeurs
c'est une infirmière du village de
l'autre côté de la rivière qu'à relayer
un message aux parents et crédules les
enfants seraient morts
on n'aime pas dit c'est possible que les
infirmières et monti dans leurs
déclarations
personne n'a été témoin c'est possible
qu'on ait menti à christine quand on lui
a dit pat était malade dès qu'il est
décédé le lendemain autre maisonnée
même drame marie-louise marque à vie de
son fils de 4 mois
robert je comprends pas pourquoi on n'a
pas averti pour aller le voir un accord
inter régions et même la direction de la
santé régional de la côte-nord
d'aujourd'hui à peine à expliquer ce qui
est arrivé aux enfants ce sûr que quand
on regarde ça après coup m'en parlez
vous nous en avait parlé
ça me préoccupait aussi tellement ce
point qu'on a fait appel au coroner
parce que pour nous il y avait beaucoup
de questions sans réponse alors pour
nous le mécanisme c'est d'appeler le
coroner pour voir si effectivement soit
ce moment là il y avait eu quelque chose
la disparition de huit enfants l'année
où les familles à ménage dans des
maisons est intrigante avancer il nous
est un nomade
ils vivaient dans des tentes hiver comme
été même s'ils ont des maisons ils n'ont
pas de service et doivent demander des
soins au village de pêcheurs de l'autre
côté de la rivière
sharmarke assure le transport car il est
le seul à avoir un bateau à moteur
mais quand même
et
les amener à la clinique de los côté
magali est trop prenait un temps fou
pour les envoyer à l'hôpital devait
attendre très longtemps les blancs passé
avant lille à mattel 1
à l'époque ils sont considérés comme des
hors la loi quelques années auparavant
on avait tenté de les sédentariser
en déplaçant toute la communauté à la
nouvelle réserve de la romaine 300 km
plus à l'ouest le missionnaires oblats
alexis genou qui en menait large chez
les innu depuis 20 ans voulait regrouper
les autochtones de la basse côte dans
une seule réserve ce qu'ils faisaient là
faire d'ottawa
c'est toujours avec la même intention de
la même stratégie
c'est un peu avec l'idée de de contrôle
et de regrouper pour mieux pour mieux
contrôler des aînés du village de
pêcheurs de sète augustin se rappelle le
départ forcé des familles
ils ont été transportés par bateau dans
la cale où on met normalement la
marchandise à faire quoi
il ne veut pas grand chose à peine
quelques temps nous avons retrouvé le
capitaine du bateau qui les a déplacés à
la romaine
la première nuit on s'est arrêté à mi
chemin année mais qu'elle les ait dit
ont pris leur tante et son talent y
coucher sur la rigueur et ne voulait pas
rester dans les batailles à gauche les i
nous considèrent qu'ils ont subi rien de
moins qu'une déportation déménagement
n'est pas assez fort relocalisation
n'est pas assez fort déportation
déportation qui vraiment met en valeur
le caractère fort c'est donc la
stratégie qui a été utilisée par les
autorités dans un bateau ok à fond de
cale
bon ça ça revient beaucoup dans les
témoignages des décennies dans un bateau
à fond de cale
c'est quelque chose au niveau de la
mémoire collective
on disait des vieux disait c'est la
terre vont être mécontents
si on sent bon quel rapport avec la
terre et qui est fondamental c'est pour
ceux qui sans apporter de la terre à la
romaine pour qu'ils aillent au pot brisé
pour pas qu'il y ait rupture
un groupe est revenu à pas quoi chipie
par ses propres moyens le printemps
suivant
le maire guy figaro paul des combats
sont retournés directory saeed khan
autant dans la rue cambon
andrew bogut que l'on voit sur ces
images a fait le voyage à pied yanka
nous un périple deux mois avec femme et
enfants malin et moins on est parti
quatre familles
à pied dans la neige
le père joseph lau a refusé de nous
aider et je n'ai pu acheter qu'un seul
sac de farine pour faire le voyage
mais ce sont les blancs qui nous ont
donné à manger en chemin mais oui ce
retour sur leurs terres ancestrales a
soulevé la colère du père genou
il envoie un télégramme aux autorités
pour couper l'aide sociale ouzzine ou
quatre familles indiennes entêté ont
quitté la romaine de la vie avril pour
s'établir de nouveau à saint-augustin
ces gens ne sont pas appuyés par les
autorités n'ont droit à aucun secours
fédéral car ils ont abandonné deux mêmes
leurs privilèges après de nombreux
avertissements stop
d'autres familles les ont rejoints par
la suite et pendant des années les innu
de pakua shipi sont laissés à eux mêmes
sans soins de santé
l'anthropologue remy savard a passé une
partie de l'hiver 70 avec eux sous la
tente et un jour god of war et à
l'esprit nelhomme arrivant au croco ou
tournant de belley je vois des étangs et
encore désert pour pacifier quel
successeur
ils étaient menés 1 3 puis de lyon
voulait mettre en réserve ou quelque
chose demain
le fédéral décide alors de leur
construire des maisons m'a pas quoi
chipie mais en y entrant les enfants
tombent malades l'une après l'autre une
punition de leur dieu croit en joko que
fatiha les esprits n'étaient pas
contents qu'on ait délaissé nos
territoires qu'on suive les décisions du
père oblat on nous a punis pour ça la
conception même de la construction des
maisons pas changer un certain nombre de
choses et me savard a été témoin du
changement de mode de vie comme les
maisons la sédentarisation le grandir en
ce moment et ont vécu au coup de chaud
au sol
l'ebit la perte de contrôle aussi des
choses c'est plus eux qui comptait céder
c'était déjà de l'extérieur robin qui
gérait des choses tellement seigneur
intel en place et puis c'était
le gouvernement a posé ce fédéral et ses
provincial les enfants disparus font
partie de ce bouleversement
leur souvenir est resté enfoui quarante
ans plus tard le mystère subsiste
personne n'a reçu de certificats de
décès ni moqueur rapport médical
personne n'a vu les enfants morts et
parents ont des doutes
tout le monde peut accuser quand ils ne
voient pas je ne sais pas lire
quand t'es pas témoin que t'as pas de
preuve c'est normal de donner
louisien marque a perdu sa soeur odette
il y a trois ans pour mettre fin à la
peine de sa mère elle brise le silence
elle cherche la trace de sa soeur à
l'hôpital de blanc-sablon quoi pour
tourner intégral j'ai demandé ce qu'il y
avait ce raid est je voulais tout savoir
mais on me dit qu'elle n'était pas sur
la liste des personnes décédées un envol
ils témoignent les vieux comme moi on
pense que les enfants ont été adoptés
regarde le cas d'élise
on nous a dit qu'elle était malade alors
qu'elle a été donnée en adoption
on l'a retrouvé à québec
je retrouve anne panassac anne qui est
il arrivé à ce neuvième enfant ça semble
être un cas d'adoption en catimini mais
cela reste a documenté mais vous
comprendrez que ça alimente et quand
même l'espoir des autres parents que
leur enfant est été adoptée qui sont en
bonne santé
tu es soit vivant on regarde la suite de
votre enquête reste avec nous parce
qu'après la pause
les parents vont découvrir la vérité
il est impossible que huit enfants
soient passés par l'hôpital de
blanc-sablon sans laisser de traces à la
demande des parents nous avons fait des
démarches officielles auprès de
l'hôpital
aujourd'hui les rapports médicaux des
enfants ou ce qui en reste vont nous
être remis
louise à croire que sa soeur est
toujours vivante qu'elle a été adoptée
n'était le manuel je suis allé deux fois
à terre leur mémoire part d'un éditeur
chaque fois je me suis senti bizarre
comme si elles étaient vivantes et elles
vivaient leur taille de machines de
manière ninine les premières réponses
arrivent après 40 ans sinon le printemps
des quiz
vous savez qu est-ce qu à la gombe je
sais que si ce qui reste l'opération
doit aussi le parti avait aussi
normalement s'adapter je pense d'une
quarantaine d'années donc selon qualité
de conservation il ya une idée une
épuration mais c'est ce qui reste de des
dossiers mode et des usagers de la dette
avec douloureusement la v11 café décédé
parce que le top 6 ont été faites le
vite avant 72 donc causes du décès un
qte
pas moyen donc une broncho-pneumonie
d'un jeune virale aiguë du révélation
pour louisa les trois frères et soeurs
de marie marque ou s'ils sont décédées
de bronchiolite ou de broncho pneumonie
même chose pour kathleen une des filles
d'agnès peau que pour son autre fille
monique surprise asphyxie le moenner par
obstruction des voies respiratoires
supérieures
ça veut dire que l'enfant est vantée
pour une broncho-pneumonie décédé parce
que
parce qu'elle essayait tout fait avec
les éléments fait ça seulement pourquoi
elles ont donné à manger alors que
l'enfant et il y avait juste au moins
important en allemand par des éléments à
pour une question difficile pour une
mère d'apprendre que son bébé est décédé
seul et tout fait on voyait avec les
choses essentielles
madeleine st gelais est infirmière
itinérante elle connaît les soins de
santé qui étaient prodigués en basse
côte nord
dépendamment de la population de la
tuque pouponnière bailly se peut qu'il y
avait peut-être l'utilisation comme ont
aussi de la petite serviette pour que
les biberons le petit bébé puisse
prendre son biberon et sort bine pendant
qu on essaie d'en changer l'eau pendant
qu'on essayait mais on avait on avait
quand même les outils d'un service de
soins primaires
autres temps autres moeurs dr camille ma
consigne les papiers c'est le médecin de
la place qui fait tout véritable icône
ici
aujourd'hui il est décédé
n'avez-vous connu docteur camille
marcoux gelé connu il avait confiance en
lui bistrot également en avant le jeu
mais je lui faisais confiance
l'instrument mais maintenant l'avion
entre man dont il n'est ni non
mais n'a jamais pu parler de ma
tristesse d'avoir perdu mes deux filles
d'apprendre aujourd'hui ce qui est
arrivé en amérique
laurent coq et rythme
même émotion chez les parents à qui nous
avons apporté des nouvelles c'est un
certificat de décès
les huit enfants qui sont partis pour ne
pas revenir son bel et bien décédé on
nous traitait comme des animaux on a
même refusé de nous donner l'aide
sociale la communauté a été abandonnée
sans aide
la mort de ses enfants a été causée en
grande partie par cette négligence ou
elle a regardé de façon plus générale
puis je les regardais avec des gens
aussi de l'équipe médicale pour voir
tirer ce qu'il ya comme une tendance qui
qui qui est là où un fil conducteur
puis ce que les remarques que les gens
m'ont fait là après leurs études
c'est que dans le fond il s'agit
d'enfants souvent dénutris qui arrive
avec une condition de santé près car
pour lesquelles il y aurait eu des
traitements fait mais malheureusement
les dessins ont été constatés le peu
temps après nous avons retracé trois
médecins qui ont été passage à blanc
sablon à l'époque ils n'ont aucun
souvenir de ses dessins en rafale mais
affirme que les enfants et nous arrive
est très mal en point
les parents ne savent pas où se trouvent
les corps de leurs enfants
les bétons et yoann c'est ce que je
trouve le plus difficile qu'on les
ramène jeux pc voire étrange que les
enfants qui sont morts là bas n'est pas
été ramenés ici tout ça étrange aussi
qu'on n'ait pas fait venir les parents
pourquoi ils n'ont pas plus de photos 1
les corps des enfants n'ont pas été
retournés aux familles un geste
inhabituel que personne n'arrive à
expliquer la coutume c'était un enfant
dé celle ci est décédé d'une maladie
connue ok on l'infirmière près par
l'enfant le nez toile l'apport et le
remet à la famille mais de dire que l'on
enterrait les aimer les enfants cinq ans
les parents les ai revus ou reçus à
trousseau difficile
les autorités n'ont pas averti les
parents de l'inhumation
nous devons donc poursuivre nos
recherches cette fois dans les registres
paroissiaux de blanc sablon
donc on garde nos archives dans le
coffre-fort ou coup il ya une fuite
oui c'est ça à l'abri du feu sont régis
là c'est la régissent de deylaud que
nous avons aussi métier et avec la dette
soit la date du décès ou le tête des des
funérailles ben là je suis capable
d'aller voir dans mon registre pour ces
années là donc vous étiez intéressé par
des événements qui sont arrivés en 71 72
j'avais la dette de robert la loge avait
le date du 12 juillet 72 donc il faut
que je fouille et là nous avons les
informations qu'il a été inhumé dans le
cimetière dans cette paroisse il est le
fils de qui et de madame elle est
décédée à l'hôpital de blanc-sablon
ennahda
enfin les femmes vont savoir où trouver
les enfants elles sont 25
c'est plus flou ils sont tous enterrés
ici ou cimetière de blanc-sablon les
registres le précise le lieu exact pour
six d'entre eux le chanteur rue robert
lalo kathleen ici louisa ne sait
toujours pas où est sa soeur odette du
goncourt sera en outre après avoir
récité le je vous salue marie
elle dépose du tabac sur le loup anonyme
au rituel pour faire le pont entre le
monde du vivant et des esprits la
dernière fois que je vous ai vu vous
êtes plus jamais atteint
ultime d'après patrick je me souviens
quand tu étais petit je t'avais échapper
je craignais que tu meurs pendant
longtemps j'ai cru que c'était moi qui
tu avais tué
mais
de mauvais
ma fille tu peux te dire adieu
maintenant que je trouve moi qui n'ai
pas pu le voir à 22h la dernière fois
que je t'ai vu tu me sourit et me voyait
la main
mais non
pendant de longues années la distance la
langue ont empêché les familles de
demander des comptes aux différentes
autorités ont décidé pour elle sans les
avertir
et aussi longtemps le sentiment de
culpabilité d'avoir quitté leur terre et
de s'être ainsi attiré la colère des
esprits les amuse lit ce long silence
entretenu des doutes qui marquent encore
la communauté